I think everyone is a freedom fighter,
I get this question asked a lot.
I think that we are all born
with the innate skill to freedom fight.
I think that some people choose to
really dig deep into that
and some people choose to not.
Alexandria Butler, thank you so much
for being with me on my show,
20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm good.
Thank you so much for having me.
How are you?
I am fantastic.
Thank you.
I'm very excited to have you on the show.
Because it's always incredible for me
to speak to people who are
so passionate about a multitude of things.
And I'm excited to both dive deep
into your experience as a program manager
at Facebook, Airbnb,
most recently now Twitter.
Also a Stanford graduate.
But I'm even more interested
to hear about you as a freedom fighter.
And that's not something that I see
on LinkedIn every day as a title.
Let's start with that.
What is being a freedom fighter?
So, I think everyone is a freedom fighter.
I get this question asked a lot.
I think that we are all born
with the innate skill to freedom fight.
I think that some people choose to
really dig deep into that
and some people choose to not,
which is really unfortunate.
And so, how I define freedom fighting
is just seeing something that is wrong
and taking the steps,
whatever steps and privilege
that you have to try to change it.
And so for me,
as a black woman in the technology industry
and coming from Stanford,
I never wanted to go into tech.
If you talk to anybody
that I went to undergrad with,
I'm sure they're still laughing
that I'm in the tech industry.
I just sort of
stumbled into it with this idea that
I'm going to be here for a year or two
as I figure out my life, and then
I'm going to go do something else.
And I realized pretty quickly
that I actually really enjoy it.
But there were all these gaps.
One being very young,
being 22, and not knowing what's going on
and really not having access
or not having a leadership
that really understood this concept.
That at 22,
regardless of what college you go to,
you know nothing about life.
In what does it mean
to bring in new college grads and say:
Okay, so we know that we employed you,
but we also know that
we need to build programs
that help you figure out how to adult 101.
Right?
And so that was really my first step
of really imbibing was.
That's where the gap was for me at 22.
I felt like I had a job.
I worked, I had management,
I had people that worked around me,
that were showing me how to do my job.
But nobody was showing me
how to be an adult.
And then I would start talking
to other people at my company
that were my age and they had the same issue.
So, I said, "Okay. So, why don't we just
require leadership to give us those skills."
Either: a. give us those skills,
b. give us the time to find those skills,
or c. give us money to bring in people
to teach us those skills.
And so, I went to the head of engineering
for the company that I was working in
because I was an engineering program manager.
And he knew me somewhat.
And I said, "I need $10,000
to start a new college grad program
because we don't know what we're doing."
Right?
And he said, "Okay. Sure."
And remember, in the tech industry,
ten grand is actually not a lot of money.
And so, I use this skill of mine,
which was asking questions and just kind of
walking and interrupting spaces and saying,
but this is what I need
to really bring together
the new college grads that I was working with.
So, at 22, that was my freedom fight.
And then as I got older, I recognized
that I have another freedom fight.
And that's being a black woman
in the tech industry.
As a black woman who was raised,
born and raised in St. Louis, Missouri,
I completely understood blackness.
I'm very aware of that.
And I'm honored to be a black woman.
I think it's the best trait about me
is this womanhood and this connection
to something as beautiful
as black Americanness.
Yet, I'm also aware that I live in a world
and live in a country that that's very
polarizing and can be very political.
And people think certain things of me
that really just fundamentally aren't true.
And so, walking around the tech industry,
I was one of my own.
There were other black women.
But either: a. they were much older than me,
or they did not work
in the same department that I did.
And so, I said, "Okay. We have to fix that."
Because I need to figure out
how I'm going to rise up the ranks.
I need to figure out
how I'm going to do well at my career.
And in order to do that, I need mentorship
from all different types of people.
But there are specific conversations
and specific understandings
that I can really only have with black women.
And so, I started a Facebook group called,
Sista Circle: Black Women In Tech
in 2017 and just invited black women
who work in tech and to go to brunch.
And now we have over 7,000 women
all over the world.
Wow.
Yeah. We partner with tech companies
to start really having these
important conversations.
And these important conversations
are not just DNI focus,
diversity and inclusion focus.
I always tell people,
"Black women do not need to be preached to
about diversity and inclusion."
Like we already know that's an issue.
But what we do need
is we need to have conversations
about how we level up in our career
because people usually exclude us
from those conversations.
So, whether it's partnering with
a tech company
and having a negotiations workshop
or partnering with another company
and talking about how do you go
from an individual contributor
to a manager and things like that.
So, how do we grow ourselves?
So we are not only prepared
for the next step,
but we know how to funnel this magic
that the world has given us
in the best way.
So, yeah, that's what I do.
So, what's so inspiring to me
with what you're saying,
so a lot of the time when I hear about
people that are passionate about
the diversity and inclusion,
and I'm personally,
obviously very passionate
about those topics myself.
But a lot of the times it's very general
and it almost seems like
I'm talking to people it's like,
well, what can I do as an individual person?
And what impact can I have?
And all of a sudden,
here I'm hearing you talk about
this very specific idea that you had:
how can I help black women in tech
support each other, aid each other,
get tech companies to come
and give us these negotiations,
workshops and classes
and help and create a supportive community?
And I can only imagine the amazing impact
you have on those thousands of women.
And the lesson that I'm taking away
from this is: we can all have an impact
in our immediate community.
We don't have to,
it's not an all or nothing game,
which is to me really inspiring.
And that's what freedom fighting is, right?
Because I always tell folk:
"My day job is not diversity and inclusion."
I happen to be a black woman
who works in an industry
that there are not a lot of black women.
I happen to be a black woman
who lives in America and has received
some of the most egregious impressions
that you could ever imagine
because of what I look like.
And so, therefore,
because of those experiences,
I'm also very aware of how
I will and will not be treated,
whether I am at work
or whether I'm at home.
And so, what happens when I stand
in that power, even when I'm at work,
not even talking about Sista Circle,
but talking about my day job
and talking to my manager
or having conversations with my co-workers,
because that's freedom fighting as well.
Right?
Being in a room and helping build a product
and raising my hand and saying,
"Hey, are we thinking about black people
when we as we're doing this?"
"Hey, have you thought about
how that may affect ABC community?
Hey, so I notice that this room
is somewhat diverse, but it'd be great
if we had this type of person in the room
to give this perspective,
because I know I can't give that
and I know all of you can't give that.
And we need that perspective
before we launch this product."
And that is really what freedom fighting is.
It's this intentionality to say that
I don't have all the answers.
So, I either:
a. The answers that I do have speak up,
or b. The answers that I don't have speak up
and literally drag the person in the room
that I think has the answer
or knows the person who has the answer.
Because that's what diversity
and inclusion really is.
It's just be the person in the room
that says something's not right.
So, if all I have to do is just
go find the person to fix this,
I have no problem sending that email.
How do we make this a norm?
So, not every company
has an Alexandria working for,
and obviously looking at your incredible lineup
of amazing companies that you've supported
shows us what you bring in to the table.
But what can every startup that's growing
or every company, what can we do
to make this more of a norm,
to keep having this mindset of:
can we think critically
about who's in this room,
who are we representing,
who are we supporting on the other side,
and who are potential customers
that we might not even be thinking of?
I always tell people
to recognize your own privilege, right?
It was funny.
I was joking with the co-worker last week
about this, and I said,
"I find it interesting that people
refuse to deal with their trauma,
but instead want to put their trauma on me,
which makes no actual sense." Right?
So, deal with yours and then come talk to me.
And to me what that means is that
in order to be that person,
you have to know yourself fully.
And to know yourself fully,
you have to recognize
your layers of privilege.
In any given situation,
you have the most privileged in the room,
you may have the middle
or you may have the least.
Unfortunately, because of white supremacy,
we identify people
based on what they look like.
But as we all know,
everybody comes from a story.
So, there's lots of privilege
that you may not see
when you physically look at my body, right?
Whether it's I,
whether it's you have a person
that comes from poverty
or whether it's you have a person
that did not grow up with a mom and dad.
Right?
Like, you may not physically see
that one themselves,
but that is a lack of privilege.
And I think people need
to really do this work.
So, a couple of years ago,
I started this workshop called,
The Privilege Workshop,
which I've been doing with a lot
of companies and groups of people to say,
"Hey, let's just be here for the next two
to three hours and figure out
what your layers of privilege are."
Because I fundamentally believe
that if you can identify
your layers of privilege,
if you can say, hey, this is my gender,
and because of this gender, it is either
a layer of privilege or it is not.
This is my race.
And because of this race,
it is a layer of privilege or it is not.
This is my educational background.
I know this is a Stanford platform.
And I always tell folks
that I went to Stanford University
and I have to own that privilege.
I went to Stanford University,
which is an elite institution
that I'm very proud of going to.
I'm not going to apologize for my degrees.
But at the same time,
I'm also aware that it is a privilege.
And most people don't have that privilege.
And I'm also not going to sit here
and pretend that I don't know
the privilege of going to a school
that helped build the industry that I work in.
Right? Like those layer's here.
You know what I mean?
It's like going to an Ivy League school
on the East Coast
and working on Wall Street.
There is a privilege there
because we all know Wall Street.
Many people from those East Coast schools
have funneled and fueled that work force.
So, I can't sit here as a Stanford grad
working in the technology industry
to not accept and identify that privilege,
whether or not I speak it out loud,
but that is there, right?
And once you identify your privileges,
if you can identify your privileges,
then you're also at the same time
acknowledging that they exist.
And in that acknowledgement,
you're acknowledging that
also, other people don't have those things.
And that's what we all need
in these workspaces,
is people to acknowledge
what's in front of them,
do not make excuses for it.
I get very tired of people making excuses
for their privilege because most of the time,
privilege is not something
that you did to yourself.
It's things that just happen this way.
It's like a deck of cards.
But honoring that privilege by saying:
so this is what it is,
and how can I give back to people
who don't have that privilege?
So, for me, for example,
how do I give back to people
as a black straight woman
working in the technology industry
with two Stanford degrees?
How do I give back to people?
Well, one,
You've done a lot.
Yes. Going back to Stanford
and helping Stanford kids in advising,
but also to making sure that I'm talking
to other students who did not go to Stanford.
So, how can I help you?
And let's have these conversations
that I'm very aware that I was having
at 18, 19, 20 years old at Stanford,
that other kids may not have had, right?
Or have had,
but never had in a technological lens
because Stanford is very techie, right?
And so, that's what I think we all need to do.
And if we all do that work
of getting to know ourselves better,
then when you walk into professional spaces,
you then know yourself.
Then you can also be aware that, like,
oh, so this person doesn't have that
in this moment.
So, how can I just give it to them
for a few seconds? Right.
I love it.
Alexandria, a lot of these things are,
we have to look into ourselves
and recognize and I think very critically,
especially in 2020,
I lived in Israel my most of my life,
I came to California this past year
to start Stanford and all of a sudden
I'm hit with this polarized area
where I'm understanding
that there are these deep rooted conflicts
which may have been brushed under the rug
for some people, obviously,
for many others it hasn't been,
and all of a sudden there is this whole
uprising of polarization of 2020,
and I'm becoming very conscious
about it myself.
But what is one thing that
every person that listens to this,
including myself and my friends,
can do tangibly to help make things
a little bit less polarized,
and help really understand that some of us
come from a more privileged background
and help those that don't?
Stop assuming that your story
is the single story of humanness
in humanhood, if that's even a term.
It should be a term if it's not.
Stop assuming that your way of life
and your way of thinking
is either the only way or the best way.
Right?
When we are born,
we come into this world with so much stuff.
A lot of that is trauma
that is given to us from our parents
and our ancestors.
Not our fault, but it is there
and you have to acknowledge it.
A lot of it is blessings and prayers
and hopes that come from the same people.
A lot of it is the environment
in which we live in.
A lot of which is religion.
Right?
With what religious texts have told us.
And I always tell folks,
I think religion is so beautiful.
I love learning about different religions.
I was raised Baptist, black Baptist
coming from the Midwest of the country.
But I think all religions are beautiful.
I'm also aware that religion historically,
including today in present times,
is used to oppress people.
These are not,
and that's not,
that's something that we have to come
to terms with, right?
And so, that's important is that
you can come to a table with people
who are nothing like you.
And regardless if you agree
or disagree with them,
you can look at them like a human and say:
but I want to actively listen to your story.
Because all of us have stories.
And our stories directly
come from our experiences. Right?
To give you an example,
I was on Instagram a few nights ago
and I was actually reading this thing
from this person
that I went to high school with.
And she is clearly anti abortion.
She is pro-life.
And I was just reading her stance.
I don't agree with her stance.
I am pro-choice.
And I'd like to say that
pro-choice is not pro abortion.
It's just pro choice for me is a side ideology
that people have a right to choose
what they want to do with their bodies.
And that's none of my business
and I should not be involved in it.
But, looking at the conversation
and the comments
with this woman that I think
she went to college with,
and I don't know this woman,
where this woman was very upset
by this person's beliefs.
And what I came from the conversation was,
wouldn't it be interesting
if both of these people just sat at a table
and had a conversation of
why they believe what they believe.
Yes.
I mean, yeah, beliefs are valid.
And especially in America right now,
this pro-life and pro-choice conversation,
is an historic conversation.
I don't want people to think
that I don't think that.
It's a very important conversation.
Especially right now
what's going on today on the Senate floor.
Exactly today.
It started a couple of hours ago
on the Senate floor.
But what happens
when we can all just sit there
and not just say:
okay, so you believe this.
But say: so why do you believe this?
Right?
Where does this come from?
And that doesn't mean
that when we finish this conversation,
I'm going to agree to your belief.
But at the very basic level,
when we finish this conversation,
I'm going to see you as a human, right?
Exactly to that point.
I have to bring this up
because I had to show a few weeks ago
with Professor Larry Diamond from Stanford.
He was one of my first professors.
He was actually the very first professor
I walked into class on my first day
which was called the spirit of Democracy.
And it was such a moving moment
because, and I brought up in that episode
is because 10 minutes into class,
he started tearing up
when he was telling us about an experiment,
him and his colleague, James Fishkin ran
called: America in one room in Texas.
They brought together a random sampling
of hundreds of Democrats,
independents and Republicans.
And for three days,
they had them deliberate with moderators.
And regardless, the change in policies
and the change of thought,
that wasn't really interesting to me,
because what to me was really interesting
was the question that they asked is,
they asked Democrats:
how do you now perceive
the Republicans across the table?
Republicans, how do you
perceive Democrats?
And across the table,
the two groups started seeing each other
as humans and started seeing each other
as a thoughtful human beings
and not as enemies
that are trying to destroy their country.
And to me, that was very moving.
Unfortunately, we don't see it
at a large scale yet.
But they proved that
with what you're saying.
That's definitely something
that's extremely valuable.
Yeah.
I think that we all have to do that, right?
And not just in America.
I think every place is polarized.
Like you're from Israel.
I'm not going to blow up your spot,
but I'm sure you've had
some over the [--]
about the Israel and Palestinian conflict.
More than a few.
Right?
And just everywhere in the world.
And I think that we have to really
just come from this place of less of defense
and more of why do you feel that way.
Because when you come from
why do you feel that way,
and then I see you as a human,
then I'm opting into maybe
not necessarily agreeing with you,
but figuring out
how can we come to a middle ground.
Right?
I always tell people
I am only polarized on issues
that literally affect my humanity. Right?
If you believe that I should not be a citizen,
that's going to be,
like there is no middle ground for that one.
If you believe that I should not be alive,
there is no middle ground for that one.
If you believe that I should be considered
a secondary human,
there's no middle ground for that one.
But other than that,
we can make a lot of work you all.
We can make a lot work.
But yeah.
The only thing that I can wish for us
and everybody else across the country
that going into this turmoil
of a few months is not even going to be
as is to have no proper discussions
and peaceful discussions.
That's the one hope I have
coming out of this election.
I don't know how feasible it is.
I think it's going to heavily depend on
on where the election goes.
But we can all hope
to have a little bit more humanity.
That's what I'm taking
out of this conversation.
Alexandria, I want to thank you again so much
for being on the show.
I had so many questions
I wanted to ask you about your different roles
at Twitter, Airbnb and Facebook.
But, the things that you're talking about here,
I think are so critical
and so incredibly important right now
for when we are.
So, thank you for sharing with me
your insights and the amazing
work that you've done.
Before we leave,
I have to ask for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
The hardest question ever.
Okay, so my first word is actually a phrase.
I'm proud to be freedom fighter.
My second word would probably
be accepting.
My third word would probably be curious.
I think all of those three things
when you put them all together
really encompasses who I am
and my professional
and my personal life, right?
Yeah, I want to know more about you,
about people and, yeah.
I love it.
Thank you so, so much.
This is great.
And thank you for being on the show.
Thank you.